not too bad yourself Pierce I'm good
mate and you are the most famous young
man in Australia after cracking the joke
that reduced the Today show host to
quivering wrecks of laughter so for the
benefit of our viewers what was the joke
a vegan and a vegetarian are jumping off
a cliff to see or hit the bottom first
who wins I don't know who wins
Society
haha
it is a very very funny joke uh I mean
obviously vegans and vegetarians won't
laugh but they never laugh at anything
because they never eat enough meat so
they're always hungry is it giving you
the the Temptation that had become a
comedian when you get older
um yeah
any other joke
you had Wonder Woman
in my yeah we wonder if it is a woman
haha